ma [ __ ] ora grazie alla suite i ragazzi
e benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono fa
vj e dolci siamo in un nuovo blog erano
secoli che non dicevo amici in astinenza
per questa frase non lo diciamo da due
settimane perché sono due settimane che
non faccio un [ __ ] blog prima di
cominciare il come al solito di razer e
collaborante della settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da silvia che ha
fatto questo disegno spettacolare la
gara ogni tanto ragazzi uscita con le
fan art e digiuno non ragazzi non so
neanch'io come fate a fare certe cose
c'è io non ho non ho veramente parole
ragazzi quindi complimentoni silvia
perché spettacolare i ragazzi non ho
altre parole giudicate voi perché non so
cos'altro dire la prima notizia ragazzi
e che veramente su steam stanno uscendo
12 miliardi di giochi funky ho visto
sono ci sono dei giochi stupendi quindi
i ragazzi a partire dal nuovo anno vi
giuro ragazzi si sarà da morire dalle
risate ma questo lo vedrete voi non c'è
bisogno di anche che me lo dica
aspettate e vedrete comunque ragazzi la
seconda news è abbastanza importante
allora dato che molti di voi lo sa lo sa
a meno che non vogliate fuori dal mondo
lo sapete che stanno per arrivare le
vacanze di natale che sono per i mentale
porter e le vacanze di natale non sarò a
casa c'è quindi non sarò qui a casa mia
nella mia cameretta in questa bellissima
sedia e di conseguenza ragazzi non potrò
fare video perché ovviamente non sono a
casa non posso fare video in giro e è
impossibile quindi ragazzi per il
periodo natalizio non non posso
registrare perché non sono a casa è una
cosa ragazzi che vi abbiamo già detto
comunque in passato e che comunque vi
serve anche a me perché alla fine dove
dove riuscire a prendermi un attimino
una pausa perché con un video al giorno
dato che ho anche l'esame di maturità
perché ovviamente sto studiando come un
maniaco e sto riuscendo a far vivere
veramente difficile davanti ragazzi
quindi alla fine mi serve anche a me
come pausa ma non è finita qui ragazzi
visto che molti di voi soffriranno
questa cosa perché lo so che che che ci
morita dentro ha fatto che non faccio
vita per una settimana e qualcosa
il 26 di dicembre che sarebbe l'ultimo
video prima delle vacanze di natale o ha
deciso di fare un video speciale che
sigurd di sicura non elette non vi dico
che cos'è perché sono non sarebbe uno
speciale è diciamo che voglio fare un
regalo di natale a tutti quanti voi e
vedrete meglio uno speciale non vi
spoiler ho assolutamente nulla
ma vi assicuro ragazzi che sarà
spettacolare quindi aspettatevi lo
speciale il 26 di dicembre e quindi
ragazzi non perdete vero perché sarà
epico questo ve lo garantisco comunque
ragazzi siccome per una settimana e
mezza circa
dal 26 da 27 di dicembre fino al 6
gennaio non farò vi do ricordatevi che
comunque ho fatto in totale 250 video
volete dirmi che non ce n'è uno che vi
siete persi quindi potete anche guardare
quelli vecchi né che morite comunque
ragazzi da gennaio recuperiamo tutto
quanto ho detto questo ragazzi direi di
passare allo scartato dei pacchi siccome
ragazzi sono due settimane che non
faccio blog
per questo blog deciso di aprire era
innanzitutto questo che è un altro
binocolo oppure un mega dildo ma spero
sia un binocolo e dopodiché ragazzi se
non fosse abbastanza aprirò anche questo
e del grandissimo quindi ragazzino non
so che cazzo si trovano dentro ma voi
pensate che sia finita invece no perché
aprirò anche questo che è una roba
enorme ragazzi quindi aspettatevi di
tutto ma voi pensate che sia finita
[Musica]
ragazzi siccome credo che qua dentro ci
sia una macchina perché altro non può
essere spero che sia meno una ferrari ho
idea di che cazzo ci sia ma direi di
partire ragazzi dal più piccolo anche se
piccolo non è la lia di andare col primo
che più che un pacco ragazzi mi sembra
un involucro di scotch
non so se devo prenderli come regali di
natale spero di sì
proviamo cos'è buon compleanno ci posso
credere tenesse ricordato il grazie
mille degli auguri di buon compleanno
anche perché io gli anni mi faccio
proprio ad aprile abbiamo una fan art
stupenda tra l'altro è fantastica ma non
mi sta ipotizzando che la mia dolcezza e
infine ragazzi c'è una spilla ddl di
death note e fanta nola per questa
questa ragazzi se permettete bellissima
e con questo di neri passare al prossimo
farlo aspettate verifiche caso c'è la
mega di luca non ho capito cos'è stato
io ma che cazzo maraga ragazzi devo
farne una copia di pezzi cos'è andato
allo stadio e fate tutti cos'è e dopo lì
che c'è una una cravatta una cravatta
che sembra quella di slider
ma che cazzo a dire di passare al
prossimo pacco quello giallo che è semi
enorme abbiamo una una favicon affari
cola e questa mi è nuova
nelle mie foto spettacolari perché mi
avete inviato delle mie foto ma che
cazzo di capelli avevo qui va bè ragazzi
evitiamo di vedere certe foto scena poi
abbiamo giustamente la nutella di turno
perché se no ma vera norma con la
scritta fa vj spettacolo e poi abbiamo
kick ass
un cappello in cappello da babbo natale
fantastico e con questo ragazzo ho
finito il pacco giallo io non mi dalla
strada nato vi faccio vedere il casino
che c'è su questa cazzo di scrivania
e pensare che ancora mi e me ne manca
uno che più enorme di tutti ragazzi
siano devo riuscire a capire chi cazzo è
sta roba
ma come fate inviarmi dei pacchi così
grossi ma mio dio noleggiate un aereo
privato non ho capito mi avete non ci
posso credere lega un regalo di natale è
epico ragazzi siete siete meravigliosi
non c'ho parole ai ragazzi il mio primo
regalo di natale di quest'anno e credo
che sia l'unico perché non mi fanno mai
regali e in questo splendido regalo di
natale ho trovato incredibilmente dei
giornali come al solito
dopodiché incredibilmente altri giornali
incredibile quanti cazzo di giornale ci
sono
non ci posso credere che il nostro
aggregati altri giornali ragazzi è una
cosa a piedi ci sono solo giornali qua
dentro è normale e potrei andare avanti
così per un qualche ora vi faccio sapere
quando finisco
[Musica]
siete meravigliosi ragazzi quindi
ragazzi io e la mia amica carta direi
che possiamo passare al fa vi risponde a
prima domanda arriva da pier luigi gigio
gang fa vi risponde ma se siamo a
dicembre perché porti ancora la
maglietta a maniche corte
allora ragazzi questa è una cosa che
allora vi spiego un secondo dato che non
ho sempre indossato diciamole le
magliette queste con la scritta fa vj e
diciamo ragazzi che ormai sono diventate
un simbolo del canale nel senso che le
metto sempre le metto in ogni video come
come metto le fan art ad esempio come
faccio a intra iniziale queste fanno
parte diciamo del mio format quindi le
metto sempre grazie a questo ragazzo
imparato resistere al freddo alle
intemperie in poche parole bear grylls
ormai mi fa una pippa può iniziale il db
dio con la cera di doraemon pacchetto a
response
ma che cazzo è scritto e dvb fare
risponde falli come si fanno i bambini
alla ragazzi questa è la lezione di
scienze by fabio j che vi dice e vi
assicura che i bambini si fanno con the
sims 3 o anche 1 e 2 va bene comunque lo
stesso basta che sia the sims egizia
foschi quando inizi in verbis virtus
rivi assolutamente scrivere dove si
scarica comprala ragazzi i verve virtus
ragazzi è il gioco che credo mi state
chiedendo di più state tranquilli perché
appena uscirà lo farò al day one appena
uscita lo compro ritengo sia stato fino
adesso uno degli indie più assurdi e
spettacolari che abbia mai provato più
innovativi diciamo quindi lo farò di
sicuro è comunque credo che si possa
prendere su steam claudia tv fa vi
risponde fa v6 fare la ruota
[Musica]
ragazzi direi che posso concludere qui
perché è un po da mettere a posto tra me
ne siete accorti con che ragazzi spero
che vi do vi sia piaciuto ricordatevi
che il 26 ci sarà il video speciale
appunto come vi ho promesso e poi ci
sarà una piccola forza di una settimana
e mezza durante le vacanze di natale ma
poi partiamo tranquillamente e quindi
ragazzi se video è piaciuto come al
solito ha scelto un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook con ivy lo
trovate la descrizione essere con
iscritti scrivetemi ci vediamo il
prossimo video ragazzi